a ver si tenemos esto del camino de una
vez a nadie le gustan las nuevas
temporadas de los simpson
'los simpson' es considerada por muchos
de las mejores series animadas jamás
creadas pero con 50 premios cientos de
capítulos y más de 29 años de emisión la
serie poco a poco se fue yendo al [ __ ]
y pasó de ser esa serie que todos amamos
ver y que nos hacía reír con sus
ingeniosas estupideces hacer solo una
serie del montón una serie que se alargó
innecesariamente puede que si te gustan
los capítulos nuevos o no pero todos
debemos estar de acuerdo en que la época
dorada de los simpson hace mucho tiempo
que pasó ya en estos tiempos del
capítulo de las temporadas más recientes
de los simpson me parece lo más aburrido
llegando a lo ridículo algo excepción
ante los simpsons deben acabar y hoy
vamos a ver por qué
[Música]
la serie siempre se ha caracterizado por
un humor ácido con críticas dirigidas a
la sociedad y básicamente a todos los
peces guionistas pusieran sus ojos
encima religión famosos políticos todo
no nos sobran críticas porque si eran
críticas inteligentes con mucho humor sí
porque el placer y la graciosa es una
comedia tenía que hacerlo pero más que
cómica era ingeniosa la serie sabía cómo
usar chistes muy bien colocados y bien
hechos para hacernos reír pero al mismo
tiempo criticar algo de la sociedad
americana en ese momento los simpson
eran expertos en burlas de la sociedad
pero eso cambió actualmente si no son
los repeticiones estúpidas y ridículas
de lo mismo pero vamos a ver por qué
bueno en mayor parte eso se debe a la
fronterización pero que es la
fronterización bueno la fronterización
es un recurso un método como quieran
llamarlo que usan los guionistas cuando
ya se les acabaron las ideas necesitan
rápidamente unas nuevas para un episodio
mediocre consiste en tomar un rasgo
característico de algún personaje y
exagerar lo tanto que se olvidan los
demás rasgos que definen al personaje
volviendo a lo molesto proponemos un
ejemplo y quien mejor que en este plan
del personaje en nombre a esto
las cosas que definen el personaje de
ned flanders buen padre buen vecino
atento religioso amable y algo ingenuo
lo que la serial hizo el personaje fue
solo tomar una de sus características
obviando las demás exageran la tanto que
se volvió la única característica
relacionable el personaje en este caso
exageran tanto la emoción de flanders a
la religión que el tipo pasó de ser un
buen vecino padre y amigo noble amante
del cristianismo a un desquiciado
fanático religioso ven ejemplos hay
demasiados homero pasó a ser un padre
algo estúpido pero trabajador y con un
corazón noble hacer un [ __ ] mental
con alcoholismo liza pasó a ser la más
lista de los cientos y uno de los
personajes más justos y amables hacer
una idiota cerca que quiero obligarse a
tener los mismos ideales que ella y que
en cada capítulo te recuerda que es más
lista que todos a su alrededor como
ejemplos hay muchos pero no quiero ser
vio más largo creo que ya entienden el
punto los personajes que nos hicieron
amar la serie ya no existen ahora sólo
tenemos versiones más exageradas y
ridículas de los originales y dado que
los personajes serán los que nos
proporcionaban todas las graciosas
situaciones que amábamos el cambio en
estos hace que las situaciones
planteadas actualmente en los capítulos
exageradas ridículas y aburridas cuando
menos la serie actualmente es una burla
sin gracia de lo que solían ser antes
los capítulos y el humor en general se
siente forzado se hacen chistes porque
deben hacerlos los mismos productores
saben que la serie no es lo mismo y es
por eso que cada cuantos en un capítulo
con algún invitado especial así tratando
de captar la atención de las personas y
queriendo ocultar la bio criatura sería
actualmente las referencias ya no son
graciosas porque antes entendían en unas
referencias pues [ __ ] al menos te
reías por la situación pues ahora no
claro que muchísimos otros factores por
los que una serie como los simpsons
fracasa con el tiempo por ejemplo si le
preguntas a cualquier persona o a la
gran mayoría te dirán que era se le
comenzó a morir con este episodio pero
porque bueno este es un capítulo en el
que nos dimos cuenta que las ideas
estaban acabando ya contra la sacaron
capítulos y eres capaz de hacer
cualquier cosa por más ridícula que
fuera así se tratara de traicionar las
creencias de los espectadores pero de
qué hablo a todas las personas de los
simpson les cogemos cierto cariño por el
tiempo que llevamos conociendo sus
historias y su desarrollo como
personajes
con skinner no fue la sección poco a
poco y con algunos capítulos fuimos
conociendo una historia este regio
director que resultó ser una buena
persona con capítulos realmente
memorables pero cuando sacar la
estupidez de que en oral simon skinner
verdadero sino un impostor ya fue cuando
los fans tuvimos suficiente llevan
varias temporadas construyendo poco a
poco el personaje y en un solo capítulo
derrumban todo lo que se había creado el
personaje hasta el momento es
simplemente estúpido
yo
soy un impostor
ese hombre es el verdadero símbolo
skinner
incluso el actor de busca interpreta
skinner arrastrar también
entendiblemente pues se enojó se enojó
al respecto diciendo que es una falta de
respeto con los espectadores y bueno
ciertamente lo fue también puede verse
llanamente que la serie no envejeció
bien la serie debutó en 1989 y en esa
época su humor era algo nuevo fresco y
algo que entretenía porque el paso del
tiempo la serie solo perdió su identidad
y se quiso adaptar a los tiempos
actuales y falló en el intento
la serie toma sus personajes nacidos en
la década de los 90 y trató de
adaptarlos a esta sociedad donde todo es
tecnología y gente que se ofende por
todo los 2000 son 20 años de diferencia
años en los cuales las cosas cambiaron
demasiado y los 100 son tal vez no
fueron hechos para estos tiempos y claro
dos personas que en su tiempo fueron
ídolos bueno no pudieron con el paso del
tiempo
en fin por último recapitulemos como
estamos haciendo durante todo el vídeo
hay muchas razones por las que una serie
puede caer con el tiempo y en el caso de
los simpson son bastante obvias la falta
de idea su extenso tiempo en el aire la
banalización de esos personajes y
situaciones el cambio de guionistas lo
forzado de sus chistes el mal paso del
tiempo son muchos como venimos viendo en
todo este vídeo y eso que tal vez me
queda más por fuera pero hay que darse
cuenta que los cientos ya simplemente
hace tiempo que no son lo que eran
la serie dejó de ser una sátira social
ingeniosa y pasó a ser un intento
desesperado por la risa próximos una
serie que jamás necesitó ser alargada
hasta este punto pero claro el dinero es
más poderoso que sus ideales los cientos
no supo manejar el tiempo en comparación
a otras series de su misma intención
como el south park que con el paso del
tiempo se vuelve más ingeniosa sin
perder su gracia su encanto consta que
la familia amarilla lamentablemente no
pudo hacer es ciertamente una pena
porque las series de las mejores jamás
creadas y yo en lo personal creo que la
serie no necesita un final lo siento no
es una serie que sigue una línea de
acontecimientos bueno
lineales valga la redundancia solo es
una serie que narran cada capítulo
ocurren sin distinta por lo menos yo no
creo que amerita un cierre inmenso no
tan técnico porque sean de rumor ando
hace tiempo de la muerte de homero sobre
dejar de emitir de ella bueno las nuevas
temporadas imitan los capítulos viejos
toda la vida pero bueno
independientemente de lo que las series
actualmente y el mal rumbo que ha tomado
para carlos por la mayoría al decir que
la serie al menos en sus primeras
temporadas son de lo mejor y sin
importar que se cree viendo una y otra
de sus capítulos antiguos ir tiene con
las estúpidas desde la familia porque a
pesar de todo los 100 son siempre mis
favoritas hasta la próxima
[Música]